- On this episode,
I'm going to talk about
Lizzie's impact on my career,
my health and talent.
Do you have it?
(light music)
Hey everybody, this is
The #AskGaryVee show
and I am your host,
Gary Vaynerchuck,
and I'm excited to fire away
with five new questions on episode four.
Fun fact about the number four.
That was Brett Favre's number
as a New York Jet.
- [Voiceover] Diligent Leaders asks,
in terms of platform social media,
is it better to self brand
or establish a name brand?
I go back and forth.
- Diligent Leaders, that's a solid question.
I think it's something
everybody struggles with.
Am I going to be Gary
Vaynerchuck on social
or am I going to be wine marketing man?
Look what happened there.
That's my answer.
What happens if you evolve?
Lot of people watching right now
started off as marketing gurus
but now sell carrot juice.
One of the things I like
about being your name
is that you can evolve with it.
You're looking at a guy
who used to do a show where I drank wine
and spit into the bucket
and now I'm doing this show
and I've been able to
do a seamless transition
because the truth is
many of us have different facets
to our personalities and so
I am on the camp of going with your name.
It's something that can stick with you.
There's consistency.
You don't have to rebrand.
I didn't have to change my Twitter profile
form wine guy to ask guy.
- [Voiceover] Blake asks,
how important is it that
your significant other
share your entrepreneurial vision?
What was Lizzie's impact
on building your empire?
- Blake, this is a great question.
Decided to get your question on the show.
First of all, Lizzie's impact on my career
is much more than I expected.
I grew up and would hear things like,
behind every great man is a great woman.
I'd be like psh.
And not in a negative chauvinistic way
but I was like, I'm hustling my face off.
I'd be working every hour.
And then you start growing and you mature
and you become a man.
Not a kid.
And the truth is I'm
actually flabbergasted
by the level of Liz's impact on my career.
Lizzie's support and I mean
utter 100 thousand percent support
is a major factor.
It gives me the head
space to be all in here
at Vayner and doing my thing
versus worrying about if
I'm five minutes late.
I'm running late taping this right now.
If I get home, it's going...You know.
It's incredibly important
in the fact if you prioritize your career.
Curve ball.
So it's massively important
to give you head space
to have as much freedom
to execute on your vision professionally
but the truth is
when you fall in love with somebody,
that person needs to take
precedent over everything else
and so at some level
if you don't have that,
well, that just comes with
the consequences of love
and that's okay too.
You may not be able to
hustle or work on it
or work on it in a clear mind space
and never give it 100 percent.
I'm able to give 100 percent
devotion to my businesses
for enormous amounts of time every day
because of Lizzie and the
way she rolls and supports.
Some people can only put
73 percent of their time
for a shorter period of time
and they're going to have limited success
in comparison predicated
on their talent as well
because talent is a variable.
So it's massively important for success
but it's not the only thing, is it?
- [Voiceover] Ryan asks,
what's the most common mistake
you see founders make
building a consumer focused business?
Ry,
there's so many goddamn mistakes
in building a consumer business
but I will tell you the,
you asked the question,
I'm going to have to keep it real here
as we do on #AskGaryVee show.
The biggest mistake I see is that
it is really hard to build a consumer app.
The ability to beat out everybody else
in the world and making something sticky
that people care about is,
I don't know why I did that,
is extremely difficult.
And the biggest mistake I see, Ryan,
is actually the fact that
people don't have talent
to actually execute a consumer product.
The audacity.
The audacity in the marketplace right now
by the young and hungry
and the old and hungry
in thinking that I'm
going to make this app
and it's going to work
is so ludicrous to me.
It's so stunning to me.
You have people who've
been career students.
You have people that have been
career corporate America people
and they think they are going to just come
and start a product
and understand the behavior
of the end consumer
better than anybody else
trying to scratch that itch
for that specific product.
That takes special talent.
Nobody wakes up and is like,
I'm going to be an NBA player today
because it just makes sense to them
but everybody right now is waking up
and saying they're going to be
a consumer product innovator,
inventor, co-founder and so the truth is
the answer to your question straight up
is lack of self-awareness
that they're not good enough to do it.
Marie asks,
what's the biggest lesson
you've learned this year?
Marie, that is a very simple question.
By far the biggest question,
biggest question,
the biggest thing I learned
and don't edit it.
I don't edit here.
Marie, the biggest thing
I've learned this year
hands down is that
prioritizing my health
is a really good idea.
The fact that I am now going to the gym
and eating healthy and I'm,
what are we Tuesday?
Is today Tuesday?
So I'm 26 days in to
26 days of working out
and times three.
78 healthy meals in a
row without cheating.
The energy level is actually
down believe it or not
because I was living on sugar
but I just feel like a
totally different person.
It was the absolute right decision for me.
It's changed my life.
I'm heading in the right direction.
I feel like a different person.
I will be on this Earth longer for it
barring crazy accident
and I'm happy about that.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
what's the best advice
you can give salespeople
in social media?
D Gordon, what's up my friend?
Just want to give you one more shout out
for the time we hung out years ago
at your family's business.
I enjoyed it.
Thanks for the question.
Biggest piece of advice
that I'm willing to give
to salespeople in this world
is actually ironically the
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
It's cliche.
I think you guys know
where I would go with is.
The truth is everybody's
trying to close too early.
It's just lack of patience.
It's not providing value.
Why in the world am I doing this show?
Is is that I missed the
limelight of a daily show?
By the way, this will not be a daily show.
Just to kill any lack of confusion.
I'm going away in two
weeks with my family.
Unlike WineLibraryTV days
where I would tape 10 episodes.
That will not be happening.
You will be missing me
at the end of August
but I will come back
with gusto in September.
It's because I want to provide value.
It's because I could be regurgitating
the same old stuff that I
believe in, core principles,
or I could go to this format
and give you value on a daily basis
on things that you're looking for
and so to me a couple things.
One, understand Facebook dark posts.
The segmentation is incredible.
Two, Twitter search.
You can pull people out one by one.
Three, LinkedIn's coming
soon with their product
where you'll be able to
focus based on titles
so you can hit up every single person
that's a CFO of financial service company
in their stream.
That's the hit up.
Not spamming them in the mail on LinkedIn.
So be tactical but understand the religion
which is provide value upfront.
How many of you who watch
this show provide value,
put out stories, entertainment,
free stuff, reply to people
and aren't just hitting up people
who have more followers
or more exposure than you
to try to get exposure yourself?
How many of you are actually
trying to provide value?
Thank you so much for
watching episode four
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Now, here's something
that's important to me.
I've been pushing this as you guys know
on my Instagram, the links in the bio,
on Twitter a bunch.
I don't like how hard I
have to throw right hooks
to establish the base
so everybody's who's watching,
I need you to subscribe up.
Subscribe up.
Because this way you'll
actually get it delivered
and you know when the show will air
every time it comes out.
So in my mission to not
bother you too much,
I need you to subscribe up.
You with a little bit of me
we are changing the q and a world
whether they like it or not.
That was Brett Favre's number
as a New York Jet.
Look at something real quick.
And it was.
I literally have to look this up.
That guy was in and out for two seconds.
I'm pretty sure.
Hit news.
Images.
There going to be any Jet
freaking photos of Brett Favre?
Okay, good.
Let's go.
(light music)
You've got...
This is definitely credits.
On this episode, I talk about my pops,
I drew someone directly in the face
for a crap question
and I really focus on
what small businesses
should be doing with itsy bitsy cash.